juste arranger ça lui dit matin il
s'appelle j'arrive j'arrive avant le
vote j'arrive à vous on a du mal à en
sortir du jeu
vous êtes occupé vous avez faites
attention avec le fait de vous occuper
de bien mais j'avais vous je m'occupais
d'aller poser une question très
bien certains coûts présenté comme un
média comme un autre oui bah je suis un
rappel un autre jeu sinon me répète vous
n'avez jamais débattu du chaos bono
valeur actuelle des désaccords la tête
mais une chemise place comme un média
objectif qui va nous arriver parce que
c'est moins intéressant après juste
qu'il est quand même type et extrême
droite voire pire de mémoire je le
répète n'ont montré trois jours mais
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il valeurs actuelles
je n'ai pas dit mais des objectifs par
ailleurs mais j'en viens à vous mais
c'est coca ne vous inquiétez rien ne
vaut un patient d'énergie villepin m'a
donc tout ça pour dire que on ne
fabrique pas des bulles médiatiques feu
vert je me disais macron cet appareil en
2016 ouais mais en fait macron 2016 il
intéressait les gens c'est exactement la
même chose on peut pas lutter contre ça
y'a pas de fabrication de deux
phénomènes et maintenant je vais vous
poser la question de ces coquerel qu'est
ce que vous foutez là ce soir en fait je
veux dire à ce qu'est ce qu'une place de
la foire c'est une émission ceci chez
vous et c'est chez vous c'est la maison
des races anciennes
jamais compris à certains moments ici
qu'elle ait des chroniqueurs sont plus
partagés passat a fait les îles et que
dans la seul moyen que vous avez trouvé
de faire parler d'eux dans cette
élection parce que en effet tout
monsieur sable 6éme république et tout
le monde se fout des provisions la
france à seville disent allez parler d
amour laurence a raison mélenchon tous
ces nouveaux gîtes essayé tout ce que
vous dites est venu parler de lui ce que
vous dites est faux études mettant des
mots vous avez répondu show étude après
étude tout le monde que le problème
numéro un des français c'est de pouvoir
d'achat faux nous avons des programmes
d'aidé sociale
la question environnementale
toutes les questions dont vous nous rase
et c'est à longueur de journée les
questions d'immigration sécuritaire vu à
travers les mers aux deux jours les ans
des faits divers ça vient toujours
derrière d'accord et m'a alors que
j'allais dire quels sont les besoins de
cette façon
c'est par les arguments qu'on y ont fait
en sorte que les gens la pricaf une
autre voie mais vous faites le choix car
pendant l'affrontement mais voilà
pourquoi je suis ici c'est pas pour le
plaisir d'être avec vous ça croyez moi
vous vois dans les tribunaux et on vous
condamne mais je suis
excusez-moi ville la gardienne et le
condamne à noter sur vos agendas si
c'est pas bien c'est la même séquence
d'avoir transformé une députée les
sociétés nous suivaient je suis bien
j'ai jamais été condamné et de monsieur
josé les policiers j'ai joué non mes
films et taisez vous ne demandiez dont
celui qu'il ait pas de soi je sais pas
monsieur moi je vous ai que monsieur
alors vous parlez jean luc mélenchon
lui
paraissait pas que monsieur mais dans le
show a été inculpé a été a pris du
sursis il est encore député moi je suis
maire du rural j'ai pas été inculpés
mais excusez moi mais s'est comporté
comme un volume vis-à-vis de policiers
de la justice et vous parlez de
l'héroïne mondiale
rappelle que le racing c'est un délit
qui dès qu'ils quittent et bien au delà
du fait que
moi je suis là je termine jamais un
problème c'est qu'on en arrive à
banaliser ce genre d'idée je vous écoute
à l'instant où on a quelqu'un comme
zemmour qui est condamné deux fois pour
injure raciale et pour pour
discrimination raciale et religieuse qui
prône la théorie du grand placement